every day our body is attacked by
several pathogens bacteria or viruses
several protozoans etc among them
bacteria and protozoans are still
manageable but viruses are pretty
dangerous so they attack our body and
our body's immune system work as a
defense system to counter that viral
attack and in this video we would look
at what are the possible ways by which
our body can sense a viral attack and
what measures does our body take to
counter that attack so the what the
viruses are like terrorists which would
break the barrier and get inside our
body but you know our body has
patrolling police officer just near our
physical barriers right so dendritic
cells work like patrolling police
officers and they can understand that
there is an invasion happen by the
viruses and all how does that do so so
see in the dendritic cell all in the
macrophages they have specific kind of
pattern recognition receptors known as
toll-like receptors and some of these
toll-like receptors such as tlr3 TLR 7
and TLR 9 they can understand which DNA
is from viral origin so they are trained
to recognize viral TST na or TS RNA and
this is how the macrophages or the
dendritic cell understand this DNA is
coming from a virus and there is
survival attack now once they understand
that there is a viral attack what
measures do they take so first of all
they go to the nearby lymph node and
alarm the T cells T helper cells now the
T helper cells would in turn activate
b-cells and make them plasma cells these
plasma cells would secrete a hell lot of
antibody against specific viral proteins
and the virus would be oxidized by the
antibodies now viral virus need to
interact with the host cell membrane
receptors with its surface glycoproteins
and in order to facilitate the insertion
of the virus inside the host cell but if
the virus is already optimized by the
antibodies the interaction between the
host cell membrane and the viral
glycoprotein would not occur as a result
it's hard for the virus to get in not
only this many of the macrophages and
dendritic cell expresses FC receptor
which can bind to the FC region of the
antibodies and intake the virus or
bacteria and break them apart with
digestive enzymes in the lysosome
so the macrophages would intake the
virus and they would phagocytosis them
and degrade them now other than
macrophages and dendritic cells there
are other cells such as cd8 positive
killer T cells they play an important
role against the rival protection so the
cd8 positive T cells has specific cd8
co-receptor and they recognize antigens
on class 1 MHC let's say a virus has
infected one epithelial cell marked here
in yellow now the virus has entered the
cell it would use its host protein
synthesis machinery to create viral
proteins out of mistake some of these
viral proteins would be degraded by the
proteasome inside the host cell and
these degraded protein fragments would
go inside the endoplasmic reticulum via
the tab transporter and going to be
loaded onto the class 1 MHC molecule
now class 1 MHC molecule generally
displays self antigen and that's a
signal that everything is okay inside
that cell but when these viral peptides
are also going to be present in class 1
MHC molecule that's in the signal to the
immune system that something is wrong
and cd8 positive T cells can detect that
that there is something wrong in in that
cell and as a result the cd8 positive T
cell gets activated and they are allowed
to engage they secrete specific enzymes
known as Kranz i'm and / foreign now
that would induce an a pop to tick
pathway now granzymes + / foreign as the
name suggests the perform only would
create a pore through which the
granzymes would go out into the host
cell now in the host cell it can
activate bead or backs which are pro
apoptotic gene ultimately it would lead
to cleavage of inactive caspase and it
would allow inactive caspere's to get
activated and as a result apoptosis
would occur also the cd8 positive T
cells expects fast ligand which would
interact with fast and also can activate
caspase cascade and thereby induce
apoptosis and end result is a death of
the target cell along with the death of
the virus which were growing inside now
you might be thinking that okay killing
yourself how does that help now by
killing this cell two important things
happen first of all the virus are
inanimate stuff when outside of a host
so first of all their habitat is
destroyed where they are growing
actively and breeding their habitat is
destroyed
second the dying cell before it dies it
sends off alarming signal and this
alarming signals are receptive by the
nearby neighboring cells this alarming
signals are known as
interferons as the name suggests it
would interfere with the viral processes
and we would look at that matter in
details so the interference that is he
created from infected and dying cell
would bind to the receptors on the
nearby cell nearby uninfected cell and
they would and there is an interferon
signalling which would be transduce
inside the uninfected cell ultimately it
would create some antiviral strategies
which would be used by the uninfected
cell that such that if these uninfected
nearby cells are infected by the viruses
that they can easily counteract the
attack so the interferon signalling
works by jak-stat signaling where
several jack phosphorylated jack
activate stat and stat localized to the
nucleus but they give rise to special
antiviral proteins right and depending
upon the which stat combination it is
working on the products are also
different for example there are protein
kinase r which can interact with viral
deist
RNA and as a result it would be the
translation it could inhibit the
translation now sorry for that but now
then you have other strategies for
example you have two five a legal a
synthase which would sort of create a
particular protein which would bind to
the viral TS RNA and it would inhibit
and it activates a rnase l family
molecule which would chop off the viral
genome now then there are other possible
substances which would block the
inhibition of final assembly and these
protein complexes are known as MX
proteins so this is how our interferon
base system can interfere
vital defense mechanism so I hope you
enjoyed this video like this video you
will get thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you